[Musique]
nouvelle édition du club de la presse
sur tv 60,18 radio sensations et
marmites fm merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce numéro de mars pour commenter
l'actualité yvelinoise ce mois-ci
nouradine agne journalistes à marmite
88,4 depuis trappe
bonjour nouradine bonjourbonjour
également un nicolas kirillovitch ce
journaliste à radio sensations 98.4 dans
bonjour à tous partement yvelinois et
puis nicolas banderille est en plateau
également journaliste à tv 78 places je
le rappelle pour les auditeurs de radio
sensations et radio marmite et les 78
disponible sur le câble les box adsl
internet et puis également avec nos
différents replay sur notre site bonjour
donc à vous trois plusieurs sujets vont
nous intéresser au cours de la prochaine
heure voici les principaux titres
c'était il ya un an la pandémie de kobe
de 19 pouces et les autorités à confiner
la population française depuis
couvre-feu dérogation gestes-barrières
font partie de notre langage quotidien
avec le directeur de cabinet du préfet
des yvelines nous allons revenir sur
cette gestion de crise par les services
de l'état le 5 février est dernier
didier lemaire professeur de philosophie
à trappes annonce avoir reçu des menaces
de mort de la part de mouvance islamiste
depuis c'est un véritable emballement
médiatique qui se déroule emportant avec
lui les habitants de la commune
retour sur un mois de déclarations de
démentis et sur ce rapport ambigu entre
les médias et la politique aussi et puis
musiciens sportifs anonymes qui sont les
yvelinoises des yvelinois du mois
réponse à la fin de cette émission avec
les choix des journalistes locaux nous
évoquons aussi tout à l'heure la semaine
de la presse et des médias à l'école et
qui se tiendra du 22 au 27 mars partout
en france
la pandémie est loin d'être derrière
nous nouvelles restrictions dans
certains départements pas d'allègements
non plus dont ceux qui sont moins
exposées à la copie de 19 thomas la
vielle bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines hier le gouvernement jean
castex a annoncé plusieurs mesures en
tout cas il a refait le point il a
surtout annoncé que dans les yvelines le
département des yvelines comme plusieurs
départements de france faisait partie
des zones sous surveillance avec une
circulation assez préoccupante du virus
cela veut dire concrètement que d'ici à
une semaine si la situation ne s'arrange
pas il y aura sans doute des
restrictions supplémentaires voire
peut-être déconfinement aussi mis en
place le week end
aujourd'hui quel quel point vous avez pu
faire avec les services de l'état
alors ce matin nous avons fait à la fois
un point de situation très précis avec
les services de l'état et il le greffé à
engager une concertation avec les élus
des départements sur les jours qui
viennent et qui sont assez décisif dans
la gestion de la crise aujourd'hui dans
les yvelines en finlande hier soir il y
avait cinq cent soixante deux patients
hospitalisés pour réseaux de police dont
41 en soins critiques ce qui représente
une occupation importante des lits de
réanimation en quarts des patients
atteints de latin de la colline pour
rappel d'ailleurs sur la gravité de la
situation dans le département
on déplore environ deux mille 2000 tués
depuis depuis le début le début de la
crise le taux d'incidence dans les
yvelines a dépassé le 250 et celui qui
avait été défini par le gouvernement
pour la prise de mesures renforcées et
donc c'est ça qui est rare à entraîner
le classent seconds des idées avec toute
l'île de france qui avec d'autres
départements ailleurs en france en
vigilance
vigilance renforcée qu'est ce que ça
signifie ça signifie que dans les jours
qui viennent
il est demandé à tous à la fois aux
services de l'état mais chacun d'entre
nous j'ai envie de dire une mobilisation
totale des seuils des chars et si
possible à des mesures plus dures ça
veut dire respecter encore plus une
soupe et l'osm en direct pour faire des
gestes barrières la limitation des
rassemblements il sera en compte
vraiment c'est que ça fait un an qu'on
le dit donc ça et on compte vraiment sur
la le civisme des populations étaient
par ailleurs dans la semaine qui vient
on va mettre les bouchées doubles sur
les opérations de dépistage même s'il ya
aujourd'hui beaucoup de capacités les
gens qui veulent des pistes et wax les
hôtesses mais ont mis les bouchées
doubles sur le dépistage sur l'autre à 6
c'est-à-dire identification des chèques
de contamination il ya des claques ouzif
sur lequel pavant des infirmières à
domicile par l'assurance maladie lorsque
des cas positifs sont détectés et puis
tout élément important le télétravail
donc l'importance de développer encore
de renforcer le télétravail et puis le
reste et je le disais du du couvre-feu
voilà ce que le plan d'action défini
dans l'est dans les jours qui viennent
si on veut éviter le week-end prochain
dans dix jours de passer à des choses
plus dures
maintenant vous cache pas que ce matin
avec les idées du département le préfet
à comment dire ah en fait à envisager
ces mesures figure il faut qu'on s'y
prépare au cas où on serait obligé et de
les déclencher le week-end prochain
nicolas pour radio sensations nouradine
pour marmite
n'hésitez pas à intervenir si vous le
souhaitez également peut-être nicolas
j'avais j'avais une question
plus sûres sur la forme de la
concertation vous parlez enfin vous
dites qu'elle a avec elle à laquelle a
déjà débuté
d'abord avec avec qui précisément de qui
parle-t-on est ce qu'on parle du
président du conseil départemental est
ce qu'on parle des emr les plus
importants de des yvelines 2 de qui
parle-t-on dans cette concertation
et puis on a l'impression et c'est ce
qu'on a entendu jeudi soir dernier avec
avec jean castex et qui a encore cette
possibilité qu'on ne soit par confiner
localement mais quand on voit que les
cours vont reprendre lundi puisque c'est
la fin des vacances on se demandait ce
que c'est possible encore de ne pas être
confinée est-ce que ce qu'on gaz
on gagnerait pas à tout de suite dire
aux yvelinois voilà préparez vous dans
une semaine on sera confiné pour qu'il
puisse aussi se préparer
psychologiquement dans leur vie de tous
les jours plutôt que de mettre ce doute
et on peut se dire bon bah peut-être
qu'on sera par confiner alors qu'on a du
mal à envisager ce qu'on peut faire de
plus et de mieux aujourd'hui chacun des
citoyens sachant que la circulation va
reprendre avec les parents qui vont
déposer des enfants à l'école qui vont
aller les chercher les enfants qui vont
voilà regard dans la cour de récré enfin
la vie quotidienne et j'apporte juste
une précision avant de faire répondre le
directeur de cabinet du préfet vous
parliez nicolas de cette situation qui
on a du mal à voir comment les choses
pourraient s'arranger avec la reprise de
l'école du côté de chambourcy par
exemple d'ores et déjà cotée à rs côté
mer aussi on a annoncé que les cours
auraient pas forcément lieu la semaine
prochaine que les écoles seraient
fermées que qui aurait il ya même des
tests de dépistage massif qui sont
organisés parce qu'il ya des variants
aux sud africains notamment du virus
brésilien aussi qu ont été détectés je
vous laisse répondre à présent du côté
de la préfecture
oui sur le sur le format de la de la
concertation cela concerne tous les
grands élus du département c'est un
format de la crise donc à la fois le
président du sénat les parlementaires du
département sénateurs et députés le
président du conseil départemental
et puis il est maire effectivement des
écrans que des grandes communes du
département les présidents des
établissements opération une
concertation avec les élus principaux du
département qui a été conduite sur la
rentrée oui
c'est évidemment un facteur de risque
important après vous savez que la
stratégie qui est qui est poursuivi par
le gouvernement c'est celle de réponse à
la crise tout en essayant de maintenir
autant que faire se peut la vie sociale
est au coeur de cette vie sociale on
avait vu durement du printemps dernier
il ya l'école et l'idée de maintenir
autant que faire se peut la
scolarisation des enfants c'est vraiment
l'idée de ces etc et de préserver si
elles étaient gradés depuis un an mais
de préserver la vie la vie collective
qui permettent aux parents travaillent
et voilà les bricoles qui sont qui sont
qui sont parents savent bien que c'est
évidemment centrale dans la vie
collective et vous parliez de chambourcy
chambourcy a connu à une situation
sensible ces derniers jours avec la
pression de variants de paris en sud
africain et donc on sera organisée à
partir de demain et dimanche une
opération de test général pour toute la
population de chambourcy et d'ailleurs
des environs toutes les personnes qui le
souhaitent pourront se faire dépister
dans la ville par ailleurs des
opérations de test massifs ont été
conduites sous l'autorité du maire de
chambourcy dans les écoles et au collège
à chambourcy et puis évidemment compte
tenu de cette situation épidémique
la rentrée va être reportée dans cette
ville dans certains établissements
dépistage donc 27 28 février pour ceux
qui suivraient les les rediffusions
cette émission du club de la presse
nicolas d'andry pour télé 78e malade est
toujours au niveau du rau confinement
local on a deux exemples aujourd'hui en
france avec dunkerque nice et les
agglomérations autour de nice comment on
pourrait imaginer des der confinement
locaux dans le département des yvelines
à l'échelon communal à l'échelon
intercommunal comment qu'est-ce qui est
sur la table aujourd'hui
alors merci merci beaucoup
bonjour à vous et merci beaucoup
question j'allais dire tout est sur la
table c'est à dire que précisément mais
dans une période de concertation est ce
que le préfet à sony et se soumet au
début c'est là l'idée alternative de 1re
confinement donc le week end sur
certaines zones du territoire quel con
ça s'est fait à dunkerque et sur le
littoral des alpes-maritimes mais aussi
l'autre option qui consiste à appliquer
sur confinement sur l'ensemble du
département avec l'idée que ça assure
davantage de cohérence et à éviter les
mouvements de population ça évite de
formes d'inégalités au sein du
département entre un territoire
voilà ces choses là ne sont aujourd'hui
je vous le dis très sincèrement pas à
trancher et donc dire est que la grande
option ce d entre eux un confinement sur
le département et un confinement sur les
zones urbaines davantage que sur les
zones rurales mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui devait être tranché à la fois
à l'issue de la concertation et puis
qu'il sera pris encore donné de
coordination par le gouvernement pour
toute l'ile-de-france pour que
évidemment les pratiques soient les
soient les mêmes sur l'ensemble
notamment du départements de la grande
couronne
noureddine à présent pour marmite oui
bonjour monsieur la vielle une question
par rapport à ce que ce qui est
notamment la ministre elisabeth bornes
lors de sa dernière intervention où elle
avait plutôt mis la pression sur les
entreprises pour faire respecter
notamment le télétravail
voilà tout toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillent actuellement ou qui en tout
cas se balade un petit peu dans les rues
juste un petit peu avant l'heure du
couvre feu
remarque que le périphérique parisien
par exemple et et remplit encore à 18h30
19h voire un petit peu plus tard qu'il
ya beaucoup de circulation que beaucoup
de l'entreprise ne respecte pas
forcément alors pour celles qui ne le
peuvent pas site impots c'est une chose
mais pour celles qui sont en capacité de
le faire ne le font pas qu'est ce qu'ils
en veulent envisager à ce niveau là est
ce qu'il ya des sanctions qui sont
prévus pour notamment puisqu'on a dit
que l'entreprise justement été également
un foyer potentiel d'expansion de cette
pandémie
merci beaucoup pour cette question je
crois que le télétravail c'est crucial
sa force est le message que que je fais
passer c'est évidemment de dans toute la
mesure du possible notamment des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont des sociétés dans
lesquelles télétravail est possible de
le renforcer encore lorsqu'on est un
jour spécial deux jours parce que même
lorsqu'on est à deux jours passés à
trois jours certaines entreprises sont
passées au 100% télétravail évidemment
ça concerne surtout les cadres savait
que évidemment les cadres sont plutôt
minoritaires dans la population
s'il y avait eu même s'ils y sont ils
sont nombreux et il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de beaucoup d'emplois qui reste
difficilement télétravail abl il croit
qu'il faut non pas être forcément dans
une logique de sanction mais dans une
logique de conviction et montrer que
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui
non seulement on a découvert il dire
depuis un ordre c'était un mode de
travail qui est possible en toute une
catégorie de la population
et deuxièmement près que dans cette
période un peu crucial est devant nous
de ces semaines à venir
c'est vraiment important de mettre le
paquet sur le télétravail est ce qui
rend plus de contrôles aussi de la part
de la préférence
alors oui il est des contrôles sur le
couvre-feu zaoui on est déjà un niveau
important de contrôle donc je peux pas
vous dire qu'on va les x partisme et il
y aura des contrôles
pourtant ciblées l'idée sur les
contrôles c'est évidemment pas de
sanctionner les braves gens qui rentrent
en pas comme vous disiez qu'ils ont pris
dans les bouchons ou que sais-je l'idée
c'est davantage de cibler des commerces
par exemple qui font de la provocation
clairement et stands ouverts en
accueillant des gens à l'intérieur alors
qu'ils ne devraient pas c'est le cas
pour certains
certains certains établissements de
restauration c'est un bas et puis
également le respect de genre qui se
déplaceraient très tard le soir sans
aucune justification et il se trouve
qu'avec les effectivement le beau temps
l'amélioration de l'allongement des
journées c'est des choses qui peuvent
arriver donc oui ça en prend leur a sans
relâche dans les jours qui viennent
cela fait maintenant un an que la france
vit au rythme du virus 8 mars ce sera
donc c'est cette période à peu près
premier confinement et était déclarée
dernière on va revenir sur cette gestion
de crise peut être un petit peu pendant
les prochaines minutes
peut-être nicolas pour télé 78 ans d
enseignement c'est la relation entre les
mairies et
et la préfecture aussi effectivement la
relation entre les maires et l'état
on l'avait vu déjà avec la crise des gis
les jeunes un gros développement de
cette relation entre l'état et les
maires
là on voit que ça use de toute son
importance notamment dans l'organisation
des tests de la stratégie de vaccination
sur le territoire quels enseignements
quelles leçons vous tirez justement de
cette crise sanitaire par rapport à
cette relation là et est ce qu'il
faudrait t'il et pas donner plus de
flexibilité plus de fluidité dans cette
relation dans l'esprit de
décentralisation et de déconcentration
oui je crois que vous avez vous avez
apporté la réponse à la question oui je
crois un des enseignements en terme de
l'action publique de cette année de
crise c'est là la qualité du travail
engagées localement avec lié avec les
maires et le fait que lorsque le préfet
le maire avancent main dans la main les
choses des choses évoluent favorablement
et on arrive à effectivement déployé les
tests déployer la vaccination la
vaccination est évidemment un élément
très très fort qui s'appuyait sur sur
les municipalités
ça s'est également manifestée au
printemps dernier parce qu'il s'est agi
de déployer les équipements protection
et d'aidé soignant et son ce couple
comme on l'a appelée à montrer avant son
efficacité parce que tout simplement il
agit au plus près le terrain il n'est
pas dans du pilotage niveau
d'hémoglobine estrade supérieur il est
dans l'action est effectivement vous le
disiez je crois que c'est aussi
peut-être une des choses qui inspire le
gouvernement dans les projets de textes
à venir qui vise précisément à
développer la différenciation local
l'adaptation réalités locales c'est
quelque chose qu'on dit depuis longtemps
et je crois que la crise a montré par la
preuve que c'était véritablement
efficace d'un nouveau texte de loi il ya
besoin de de faire des modifications
législatives pour pour le faire du coup
parce que je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
procédures aujourd'hui de deux textes
qui effectivement limite les
possibilités d'aller plus loin en temps
normal en dehors donc de la perte de
crise sur les projets d'aménagement sur
tout des politiques publiques qui sont
réglementés à des niveaux qui sont trop
éloignés de la logique c'est vraiment de
se placer en proximité du terrain en
période de crise on a vu que ça
fonctionne et il faut effectivement
libéré cette initiative locale sur sur
le long terme de cette période de crise
depuis un an les services de la
préfecture dans le département des
yvelines en tout cas on était
complètement restructuré et réorganisé
est ce qu'il ya des modifications
significatives ont été apportées depuis
un an le les services de l'état c'est
vrai à la fois les services du préfet
les services de l'agencé régionale de
santé qui à rendre hommage au tour de
marion sinaly un travail formidable
d'engagement au jour le jour à toutes
les étapes de cette crise se sont mis en
mode gestion prises avec l'idée eux il
fallait alors évidemment surtout au
printemps où toute l'activité était
centrée sur la gestion de crise
maintenant le reste
le reste des activités ont repris et
donc et donc aucune également nos
services l'idée c'est de d'adapter
l'organisation à la gestion de crise
avec cet accompagnement qui a été fait à
chaque chaque étape de la crise d'abord
s'assurer au début de la crise de
l'approvisionnement en matériel pour les
services hospitaliers apporter du
soutien aux opérations de mouvements de
malades vraiment le le coeur des actions
du printemps également au printemps le
l'approvisionnement les livraisons des
basques se souvient que ça a été
difficile très difficile au début de la
crise et puis progressivement la machine
s'est mise en marche
il faut départementale autour du thé
services de l'état à l'automne ça a été
la politique de déploiement des tests
avec l'ouverture est une spécificité
évinoise un des trois centres de
dépistage permanent géré par la rs en
plus de toute l'offre proposée par les
laboratoires privés et donc ces trois
laboratoires à forte capacité ont permis
à l'automne véritablement offrir l'accès
aux tests à la population
et puis depuis le mois de janvier le
déploiement de la vaccination dans le
département avec les neuf centres de
vaccination qui soit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ouverts et avec un bilan qui
est à la fois modeste et en même temps
il suffit la livraison des doses
j'ai envie de dire chaque dose qui
arrive dans le département et dans le
jour d'huile dans le bras dit noir 70
mille doses ont été injectés depuis
depuis depuis le mois de mois de janvier
en fendant les doses mais une lime et 2
est punie sur le public prioritaire
qu'est celui des plus de 75 ans on a
aujourd'hui dans le département vacciner
à peu près 80% 78 % des résidents dans
l'est dans les ehpad
donc on n'avance pas suffisamment vite
évidemment pour les centaines de
personnes qui sont sur liste d'attenté
dans les différents centres de
vaccination les perspectives c'est pour
le mois d'après une arrivée plus
massives de vaccins ce qui devrait
permettre de
de prendre en compte ses besoins de
rendez-vous dans les différents sens le
club de la presse sur tv 78 traduire
sensation partenariat aussi avec marmite
se poursuit donc pour ce mois de mars
avec le directeur de cabinet de la
préfecture des yvelines nouradine
nicolas si vous avez des interventions à
faire nouradine ont été rapidement
monsieur la vielle par rapport à la
vaccination vous disiez que voilà on
n'était pas très très rapide en ce
moment on sait que la vaccination est un
des enjeux majeurs pour notamment
permettre d'y voir un petit peu plus
positivement dans la suite de cette de
cette de cette pandémie qu'est ce qui va
faire que cette campagne de vaccination
va s'accélérer puisque là on est encore
loin loin très loin du compte
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des
personnes dans les ehpad qui on est et
qui ont été vaccinés non encore très
très loin des millions de personnes qui
doivent encore se faire vacciner
sauf à faire peut-être comme un fait
israël qui avoue t-il est quasiment
toute sa population mais à mais à quel
prix entonnant notamment voilà les
données de santé à des groupes privés
voilà qu'est ce qui peut faire avancer
cette campagne de vaccination parce que
nous sommes très très en retard alors en
retard ça dépend ça dépend ce qu'on a
les courants se trouvera effectivement
l'exemple aux hits et de l'état d'israël
est assez exceptionnel avec le royaume
uni
je me dis si on regarde par exemple les
vaccinations le prix miss n'a montré
hier des plus de 75 ans qui encore une
fois est le public cible la france a dû
tout en retard par rapport aux européens
je vous mentirais si je disais que l'on
va au rythme on voudrait que tous les
gens qui veulent avoir accédé sont
vaccinés
donc la stratégie c'est évidemment dès
que des doses sont à disposition du
département elles sont fournies aux
centres de vaccination elles sont
fournies aux différents modes de
vaccination dans le département du coup
lorsque en avril une arrivée massive de
vaccins va arriver par une
multiplication plus du double voire plus
du triple de doses arrivera en avril
la logique va être d'ouvrir de nouveaux
centres de de renforcer de densifier les
centres existants et donc de répondre à
la demande donc le l'horizon l'horizon
quand se fixe pour un véritable rebond
de la vaccination c'est le mois d'avril
aujourd'hui encore une fois on vaccine
avec toutes les doses qui sont
disponibles le département des yvelines
d'ailleurs en ile de france est plutôt
dans le haut du panier ça chacun peut le
vérifier de temps sur internet s'est
donné son som son public
voilà dès que les doses arriverons nous
renforcerons notre dispositif
nicolas vous avez peut-être une dernière
question pourra dire sensations à ce
propos je pense je pense qu'on a fait
tout juste savoir est ce qu'il ya des
nouveaux centres de vaccination dans ce
cas là qui vont voir le jour sur le sur
le territoire pendant ce pas justement
ces choix là qui peuvent être faits pour
accélérer aussi la logistique quand les
camps les vaccins vont arriver pour
accélérer la diffusion alors là aussi on
est dans une logique de concertation
avec avec le territoire parce que les
neuf premiers centres qui ont
verdissement aujourd'hui en
fonctionnement ont été libérés videmment
en concertation avec les élus au niveau
des intercommunalités
l'idée avant l'ouverture de ce nouveau
centre s'est déjà sur le périmètre
actuel réussira à faire ce qu'on appelle
lé aller vers les gens éloignés du
vaccin parce que comme vous le savez
toute une partie de la population
évidemment et notamment dans la
population ciblée de 75 ans n'a pas
accès à une eau libre où elle aura du
mal à s'en servir et dans des
territoires qui sont trop éloignés des
centres de vaccination donc à partir de
la semaine prochaine notamment dans la
communauté de communes de gally mouleres
le
le conseil départemental de concert avec
la rs va mettre en place un bus de
vaccination qui se rendra auprès des
populations les plus en vue ce soir
et puis je le disais donc en avril avec
l'arrivée plus massive de nouvelles
doses nous engagerons une conservation
de nouveau avec avec le territoire pour
envisager un loup l'ouverture de
nouveaux centres là où les besoins sont
identifiés et on avait déjà identifié
des endroits qui étaient en besoin de
vaccination supplémentaires et puis
deuxièmement là je disais la
densification des centres existants
parce qu'il faut aussi qu'on prenne en
compte le besoin de de productivité et
des centres et il faudra que les centres
existants soit mieux doté en doses et
puisse procéder à davantage de
vaccination thomas la vienne nous allons
dans un instant avec les journalistes
locaux ont évoqué la situation à trappes
propose de rester avec nous encore juste
quelques instants juste le temps déjà
d'écouter est cet extrait d'interview
c'était le 12 février dernier chez nos
confrères de lci
je ne suis pas sur les réseaux sociaux
mais le commandant de police d art et
m'a expliqué que tu rappes était en
ébullition que la ville entière
discutaient de cette lettre et beaucoup
de gens tenait des propos haineux contre
moi en accusant d'islamophobie de
racisme de stigmatisation de cette
population et ses attaques évidemment
après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit sont
une manière de me désigner comme une
cible
vous vivez dans la peur aujourd'hui non
malgré ce qui est arrivé à semelle pâtit
vous y pensez forcément oui j'y pense
quand je sors et que je rentre du lycée
je vérifie que mes portières sont bien
fermées je vérifie que je ne suis pas
suivi et quand je me rends mon domicile
de la façon le 12 février dernier didier
lemaire professeur de philosophie à
trappes annoncé être victime de menaces
de mort et sous escorte policière pour
se rendre à son lycée à la plaine de nos
fils parlait d'une commune aux mains des
islamistes définitivement perdu du côté
de la préfecture des yvelines sans
revenir sur toute la polémique et qui se
poursuit d'ailleurs encore sur le
soutien plus ou moins à porter ou non
les propos des uns et des autres je
voudrais savoir quelle est quand même la
position de la préfecture aujourd'hui
est ce que vous avez eu des échanges
avec didier lemaire depuis le 12 février
et puis aujourd'hui at il une protection
qui vais vraiment apporté une île
un merci beaucoup de poser ces questions
le dit et le maire d élever l'automne un
dès le mois de novembre lorsqu'il a
publié une tribune effectivement sur la
lutte contre l'islamisme à trappes dans
les yvelines dans les quartiers en
général a fait l'objet d'une attention
particulière des services de sécurité
des forces de l'ordre ça s'est traduit
par des patrouilles régulières et des
prises de contact avec lui et donc ça
s'est poursuivi jusqu'à début février
puis il a pris des positions vous
l'avais dit dans le débat public
national qui ont entraîné une polémique
vivent pour le moins et à la suite donc
de ses prises de position c'est pallier
à ces cours ou à des menaces aux cinq
sens et à son enseignement mais à la
suite de ses lectrices de parole
publique effectivement et du contexte et
de risque autour de lui le préfet a
demandé aux ministres à l'intérieur
qu'il a accordés la mise en place d'une
protection rapprochée
il bénéficie élections rapprocher
aujourd'hui par des fonctionnaires
spécialisés du ministère de l'intérieur
et à la suite quand une fois des
polémiques intense qui sont nés sur la
ville de trappes sur la situation de
l'islamisme dans les yvelines
le maire de trappes a également reçu des
menaces importantes et une protection
rapprochée a également été mise en place
autour du maire de trappes
voilà la situation de sécurisation des
intéressés aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à la fin février il y en
aura beaucoup de choses à dire dans la
suite de cette émission sur ce sujet
merci thomas la vielle d'avoir été avec
nous directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines
le club de la presse va donc se
poursuivre merci encore bleus allaient
nous allons continuer à évoquer dans le
club de la presse cette situation à
trappes et interagit tout de suite avec
nour adding parce qu'il n'est pas sur ce
plateau mais je le voyais il souhaitait
intervenir sur cette question et ça va
me permettre d'être juste avant tout à
fait transparent aussi avec
téléspectateurs et auditeurs
nous n'avons pas poursuivi la
conversation avec le directeur de
cabinet de la préfecture parce qu'il
n'était pas prévu à l'origine que nous
abordions ce sujet de la situation à
trappes il intervenait pour parler de la
situation du coc vide mais je tenais
néanmoins à faire un point avec lui pour
voir aujourd'hui quelle était la
situation concrète et la protection
qu'ils étaient apportées à didier
lemaire voilà revenu sur la situation
donc à attrape on a l'impression
aujourd'hui que rien ne change depuis
vingt ans peut-être même plus la ville
est présenté comme une bombe à
retardement un nid à d'islamistes il est
vrai que depuis cette commune de
nombreux jeunes sont partis en syrie
noten de notamment pour faire le jihad
la guerre sainte pour autant
l'emballement médiatique n'est-il pas
trop fort plutôt de se prêter au jeu des
déclarations dans les médias nationaux
les élus les responsables politiques ne
devrait-il pas cherché à des solutions
d'une part et puis protéger la plus
grande partie de la population aussi
celles qui aspirent à vivre normalement
et qui vit normalement calmement et qui
se retrouvent et stigmatisé devrait
revenir sur une date 2004 un
documentaire est diffusé sur la deux
dans envoyé spécial trappe
à l'heure de la prière c'est le nom de
ce documentaire pendant une heure on y
voit une ville où l'islam est politisé
fondamentalistes il défie la république
il s'est emparé de toute la commune
derrière il ya eu des jours
d'intervention de débat au niveau
national avec des déclarations et depuis
rien le sujet passe de mode
aujourd'hui c'est un peu le même schéma
qui se reproduit énorme médiatisation
des informations qui sortent qui ne sont
pas forcément vérifiées par la presse
nationale
el nour a dit mme vous êtes journaliste
sur la commune cette commune de trappes
vous la connaissez bien comment vous
pouvez analyser cet emballement
médiatique à chaque fois autour de cette
ville de trappes et comment le
vivez-vous aussi parce que cette commune
vous y êtes attaché et je vous dis
encore une fois vous la connaissez bien
parce que vous avez deux heures où ils
faits d'amour
je regardais le temps qui nous reste et
pour l'émission c'est pas sûr
effectivement je pense que trappe c'est
une ville qui de par voilà de par sa
richesse est également de parler les
paradoxes qu'elle peut porter est une
ville qui a toujours intéressé les
médias
on y parle souvent bon pour être
caricatural des diamètres de vous en
remercie nicolas anelka et consorts et
en même temps on donne souvent le nombre
de jeunes qui sont partis en 2015 2016
pour rejoindre les terrains en irak ou
en syrie pour faire pour faire le diable
je pense que c'est une ville qui a cette
voie là certains parlent d'une image et
je déteste cette expression mais bon
c'est une expression qui avait été
utilisé par ariane chemin et raphaëlle
bacqué pour quand elle avait sortir leur
livre la communauté en disant que c'est
une ville romantique en quelque sorte
voilà je pense qu'il ya un petit peu de
vrai dans ce qu'elles disent mais bon
voilà je pense que c'est surtout pour ça
qu'elle quelques elle fait beaucoup
parler nicolas kirillovitch vous si je
voudrais vous entendre sur ce sujet là
tout simplement parce que comme nous
radine
et comme tv 78 aussi vous avez été
sollicité par les médias nationaux on
parle de cet emballement médiatique est
plutôt au bout d'un moment les médias
nationaux se sont rendus compte qu'il y
avait des médias locaux alors là aussi
un pur c'est l'occasion à travers ce
club de la presse de d'exposer tous les
tous les sujets c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
quelques interventions de tweets des uns
et des autres ce soit vous nicolas pour
radio sensations où nous notre côté télé
78 où on a aussi on s'est aussi
manifestée en disant il ya des médias
locaux voilà les médias nationaux nous
ont re découvert nicolas comment vous
avez vous vécu ce moment cette
médiatisation et puis comment vous
regardez du côté local cet emballement
nationale c'est vrai que c'était assez
assez effarant et un bon on lui disait
on elle eu la possibilité de s'exprimer
dans les médias nationaux mais plutôt
sur la fin
la polémique bon après y'a pas de
l'intérêt pour nous à intervenir non
plus au début mais c'était effarant de
voir comment aussi la machine médiatique
peut s'emballer et comment elles
marchent aussi et voir comment elle peut
aussi écrasé dépasser les élus locaux
qui je pense dans leur ensemble se sont
fait complètement dépassé par les
événements parce qu'en fait la trappe
s'est fait aussi happer par par
l'actualité nationale
déjà il ya eu une annonce par le
tribunal administratif de versailles de
l'annulation de l'élection c'était le 3
février donc deux jours avant la
publication de la tribune de didier
lemaire donc déjà voilà localement ça
commençait un peu à bouillir
on sait les antagonismes qu'il ya entre
les différents personnages leurs locaux
à trappes
et puis il y avait aussi ces discussions
sur cette loi dite séparatisme tout ça
arrive au même moment et là on voit que
que peut-être que trappe alors je ne
suis pas du tout dans le complotisme
sais pas c'est pas mon idée mais c'est
vrai que quand on voit ces c'est ce
calendrier comment comment il fonctionne
on se dit que peut-être que tu rappes a
servi d'exemple à certains qui voulaient
bien montrer qu'il y avait un problème
avec avec l'islamisme en france et que
comme le disait jean ba trappe c'est un
peu l'exemple l'exemple au parfait parce
que c'est une ville qui est très
complexe où il ya eu et c'est documenté
des départs sur des théâtres de guerre
donc voilà je pense que le trap s'est
fait dépasser par la situation et que
ces élus locaux sis dans leur ensemble
à droite comme à gauche aussi et la
machine médiatique national on s'est
quand même marche elle a besoin de ces
histoires là et donc les médias locaux
dans ces cas-là n'intéresse pas beaucoup
allez-y noureddine oui juste une petite
phrase pour dire revenir sûr que vous
disiez tout à l'heure où les frites par
rapport au fait qu'ils ont découvert
qu'il y avait des médias locaux
moi j'ai été sollicité par plusieurs
médias pour intervenir mais à chaque
fois
voilà vous savez j'ai un peu
d'expérience maintenant wilfrid à chaque
fois je demande quel va être le le
format dans lequel on va pouvoir
intervenir et à chaque fois on vous
propose quatre minutes par ci deux
minutes par là où cinq minutes par là or
c'est un problème complexe et oui vous
oubliez 2 et le tout à l'heure alors
déjà le niveau local je n'arrive pas à
vous donner deux heures dans ce club de
la presse alors oui mais gina après le
club
le club de la presse c'est particulier
parce que voilà c'est une émission qui
parle un petit peu de tout ce qui se
passe autour
on y consacre pas forcément voilà ça 50
sur un seul sujet classique
effectivement malheureusement et plus
nous on se connaît à wilfrid dont
concert on prépare les émissions on sait
à peu près ce qu'il va s'y dire beaucoup
de je pense que même nicolas ça va ça va
être son cas il sait pas il peut même
être récupérée dans un tourbillon
médiatique on peut récupérer des
morceaux de boot maroc de ce qu'il va
dire pour lui faire dire complètement
autre chose ou bien peut-être même le
placer dans le camp des islamo gauchiste
parce qu'elle aurait eu le malheur de
dire que matra peuvent écouter on a vu
des choses positives on dis pas que tout
se passe bien après on n'a jamais dit ça
aucun média local n'a jamais caché ce
qui se passait à la trappe
c'est juste que c'est plus complexe que
ça il ya beaucoup plus de choses il ya
des choses positives négatives mais nous
on essaie de mettre en avant tout cas
toute la complexité du problème et pas
seulement parler de cette sollicitation
justement des médias nationaux et
quelquefois c'est cet emballement qui
peut aussi permettre aux médias
nationaux de prendre des bouts de phrase
qu'on ce qui concerne tv 78 lorsqu'on a
été sollicitée justement il ya eu
beaucoup de réticences de ma part très
clairement pour pour intervenir aussi
parce que j'avais très peur de la petite
question des petits mots qu'on cherche
du bon mot qu'on cherche à faire et
ensuite d'en fermer aussi notre média tv
soixante dix huit dans une case en
disant voilà soit ben vous avez vu ils
le disent tout et noir attrapé il ya de
la radicalisation ou alors à bas loyer
bah non en fait tout va bien et c'est de
l'islamo gauchisme
c'est très compliqué aussi de se
positionner c'est ce qui s'est passé par
exemple avec moi j'étais moi au début
j'ai pas compris pourquoi par exemple le
maire de trappes avait fait venir
jean marc morandini j'allais je me suis
dit en dix ans d'ailleurs je crois je
pense que ça vous a un peu énervé mais
c'est normal à juste titre wilfrid et
nicolas en disant que bonds a là au
moins ils viennent sur le terrain oui
voilà tout à fait sûrs que
moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a surpris c'est
comme si en fait alors moi j'ai rien
contre jean marc morandini ya pas d
aucuns prendre avec lui mais c'est comme
si en fait tu attrapes on ne connaissait
pas
en tout cas la mairie trappe c'est comme
si on se connaissait pas jean marc
morandini qu'on savait pas un petit peu
le style des missions qu'ils faisaient
et du coup on se retrouve avec des
images ne complètement caricaturale du
maire de trappes avec une dernière
séquence devant le commissariat de
trappes devant un élu du rassemblement
national
on tomberait avec des habitants dit
qu'est ce que ça donne aussi comme image
et puis après la capacité de nuisance
des chaînes d'information sera toujours
plus importante que ce que nous on va
pouvoir dire ou faire et vous le voyez
dû justement dès que ali rabo a fini son
duplex son espèce de voyage en terre
inconnue à trappes avec jean marc
morandini pendant toute la semaine ils
ont décrypté ce qui s'était passé sur
trappe en disant que toute façon le
maire de trappes était dans la duplicité
et tout ça est ce que ça valait le coup
de faire ça moi je pense que non mais
vous pourrez parler de la responsabilité
des politiques on va bientôt nommer
nicolas landry à présent une ligne plus
nous comment sur la manière dont tv 78 à
travailler sur ce dossier
finalement on a sollicité didier lemaire
il nous a jamais répondu
il préférait parler aux médias nationaux
mais ça peut se comprendre parce que ben
ça fait plus de lumière et ça c'est sûr
qu'il va être plus entendue
même chose pour alliera b on l'a
sollicité il nous a pas répondu ensuite
nous avons été sollicités par bfm tv
pour qu'on y aille
grégory est allé sur le plateau de bfmtv
pour parler de la situation mais
finalement c'était après la polémique
finalement on n'a pas pu traiter de la
même manière cette polémique
peut-être plus traités de la manière
plus sain plus proche en fait plus de
proximité en mettant ce que nous on peut
voir au quotidien
on n'a pas pu le faire parce que baisse
ses interlocuteurs là ne nous ont pas
répondu parce qu'ils ont préféré aller
sur les médias nationaux pour aor plus
de lumière donc on peut se dire
peut-être que derrière effectivement il
ya de la politique
effectivement à l'emballement médiatique
au niveau national parce que c'était ça
qui était au coeur de notre sujet
derrière ça on voit aussi que les
politiques locaux et on parle du maire
de trappes
à ce jour il n'a toujours pas répondu à
notre sollicitation ce soit directement
en ligne ou par les réseaux sociaux on
n'a pas réussi nous notre côté atv 78 il
me semble que radio sensations ce n'est
pas le cas nous radine est-ce que vous
avez vous du nouveau et des retours est
ce que le maire de trappes va s'exprimer
sur votre antenne jeu
non mais je suis honnête allez je vais
vous dire la vérité je devais recevoir
normalement monsieur le maire de trappes
la semaine dernière mais c'est plutôt
moi qui vais poser un lapin parce que
j'ai eu un contretemps de dernière
minute donc et puis depuis on n'a pas
réussi à retrouver un créneau dont il
n'y a pas eu de volonté je pense d'eux
en tout cas pour marc mais ce parcours
marmite évidemment je parle pas le bon
bout
il n'y a pas eu de volonté de deux tu ne
peux pas parler avec ce média local
mais après la question qui peut se poser
aussi c'est que les certes il ya un peu
plus de lumière voilà dans l'est dans
les médias nationaux
mais il est sûr que si le maire des
trappes par exemple coup didier lemaire
viennent sur nos plateaux respectifs
si on prépare bien sûr serment
sérieusement les émissions ce qui est le
cas pour rapport pour pour vous aux
messieurs je le dis comme ça les gens
entendront bien voilà si on prépare
sérieusement d'évitement évidemment
évidemment si on prépare sérieusement
nos émissions on connaît mieux le
terrain que bfm tv ou que le monde que
n'importe quel autre acteur donc on
n'est plus en mesure de titiller aussi
les acteurs des acteurs locaux y compris
didier lemaire ça c'est sûr didier
lemaire d'attac concrètement on l'a
contacté on a réussi à récupérer
effectivement son numéro de téléphone on
en compte a contacté une vingtaine de
fois nous avons jamais eu de réponse est
la dernière sollicitations que j'avais
pu lui faire des propositions c'était de
venir sur ce plateau est d'essayer de
convier également le maire alliés arabes
est qu'ils puissent avoir un échange
puisque al arab est demandé à avoir un
échange donc quoi de mieux qu'un plateau
locales et ans avec l'intervention aussi
des autres médias que ce soit vous radio
sensations ou pour marmite pour venir en
parler je veux montrer un autre extrait
parce qu'on parle de la responsabilité
des politiques dans cet emballement
c'est un extrait
d'un entretien dali rabais qui a été
réalisé par benoît hamon ancien ministre
ancien député de la circonscription qui
a lancé sa chaîne de télé en ligne avec
un abonnement de 5 euros par mois il
réaliser des interviews il a reçu ali
rabais les deux hommes se connaissent
très bien
écoutez cet extrait quand on m'invite
sur les plateaux on commence par ça
est-ce que vous soutenez ce professeur
qui est menacée de mort dans votre ville
certains qui disent qu'ils aient menacé
de mort par ses élèves lui n'a jamais
dit ça rend plus pour le coup il a déjà
débuté assez de mensonges comme ça mais
il n'a jamais dit ça pourquoi est-ce que
des journalistes sérieux là parce qu'ils
sont passés à va peut-être non parce
qu'ils ont déjà l'air l'éthique des gens
qu'il voit sur nos plateaux depuis 15
ans benoît des gens comme pujadas des
gens comme laurence ferrari relaient
complaisamment sans réfléchir sans
vérifier des affirmations qui sont
faites et pire que ça va sentir le rap
c'est peut-être parce que au fait qu'ils
sont tous allés ce qui est dramatique
c'est que ils prennent pour argent
comptant
une représentation une vérité qu'ils
ignorent complètement pourquoi parce
qu'ils appartiennent toutes à des
milieux disons le clairement qu'ils
passent le périph pour prendre l'avion à
charles de gaulle étoile ou aller voir
un match où logent au stade de france à
un moment donné où les journalistes
doivent arrêter de faire le buzz pour
faire le buzz doivent arrêter la machine
folle de l'emballement et la réaction en
chaîne qui est déclenchée doivent dire
bon sur ces faits déjà il ya un démenti
formel
quarante huit heures après le
déclenchement de la polémique mais ils
choisissent de ne pas le faire ils
choisiront entre choisi d'entretenir le
mensonge plusieurs jours d'affilée et
d'entretenir le flot de haine qui s'abat
notamment sur ma ville extrait de sens
tv.fr très très clairement nicolas
kirillovitch vous fait réagir
je vous le dis moi à titre personnel
j'ai du mal à comprendre cette séquence
cette séquence où le maire ali rabais ne
comprends pas ces réactions des médias
nationaux des déclarations des uns et
des autres mais quelques jours plus tôt
on en a parlé tout à l'heure jean marc
morandini vient dans la ville fait cette
déambulation en territoire inconnu et le
maire de trappes est surpris et quitte
plusieurs fois revient sur cette
séquence et même au début il remercie
d'être venu pour finalement lui dire
qu'il a mal fait son travail en lui
mentant enfin j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre tout ça et après ils sont
surpris et et entre politiques qui
s'interrogent pour se dire ah ben oui
les médias nationaux
il joue agenda publié lors leur agenda à
eux et on est victime victime je crois
qu'il faut un peu complice non je crois
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure je crois que à l'érable et et
puis la classe politique locale dans son
ensemble a été dépassé par ce qui sait
pas ce qui s'est passé
attraper que à l'érable a peut-être cru
bon au début de voilà de intervenir dans
le dos monter au front pour régler
quelques problèmes mais la machine
médiatique national est tellement forte
est tellement puissante que lui-même ses
flux entre guillemets permet enfin
excusez moi pour l'expression mais il
suffit qu'il s'est fait broyer et
aujourd'hui il se plaint des pas ce qui
s'est passé alors qu'il est en partie
responsable de ce qui s'est passé nous
rater la très bien très bien elle
expliqué et pour être tout à fait précis
alors nous radio sensations on n'a pas
été en contact direct avec avec tegra b
mais on va recevoir dans la foulée de
l'émission sandrine grand gant un petit
et sa première adjointe à la mairie à la
mairie de trac en charge de l'éducation
et de la culture et on a reçu aussi
othman nasri qui on le sait est son
principal opposant à la ville première
adjointe un premier vice président à la
région ile de france et c'est là aussi
on voit un peu l'ampleur nationale 2 de
ce débat donc donc on n'a pas eu à lire
ab nous mais on a eu on va avoir 100
migrants granby et othman othman la
secousse assez pour boucler la
discussion de tout à l'heure noureddine
et puis j'en profite je relance cette
invitation et aussi avec vous autres
médias n'en a pas parlé avant mais
peut-être organisé un plateau commun
pour recevoir alliés arabes et didier
lemaire et pour parler peut-être plus
sereinement aussi de la situation et de
la réalité cette commune qui une
nouvelle fois oui est touchée par des
questions de radicalisation et oui il ya
eu ces départs en série et il ya des
problèmes dans cette commune mais aussi
d'autres choses et aussi des choses qui
fonctionnait des habitants qui vivent
normalement
wilfrid effectivement c'est avec plaisir
qu'on fera qu on fera ce plateau pour
parler avec un petit peu plus dark
heureusement surtout qu'on est en train
de s'éloigner du du climax si on peut
dire de ce qui s'est passé
des derniers jours et que là on est les
médias nationaux sont déjà passés à
autre chose pour revenir sur la séquence
2 / sens tv donc la télé qui a été lancé
par benoît hamon non là c'est dans un
contexte particulier
benoît hamon qui a créé génération s à
voile a été un proche de la lyre à béton
qui sont dans une discussion qui est
aussi politique c'est un message
politique aussi qu'ils en voient
peut-être par par ce biais là même si
sur ce que dit haïr avait déjà content
moi je déteste le fait de dire les
médias alors que il parle de médias bien
précis et d'ailleurs on pourrait se
poser la question pourquoi il va danser
médias précis puis il critique alors que
ces médias sont clairement voilà quand
on parle par exemple de ses news
voilà il ya clairement il ya une ligne
éditoriale quoi donc on aime la scène
politique d'ailleurs décidé de les
suivre
il ya certains mais certains hommes
politiques qui ont décidé de ne plus
intervenir parce que vous savez très
bien où ils vont tomber le dise
clairement ces voix là ils assument de
ne plus y aller ils le disent clairement
après ça c'était on est dans une
démocratie
les idées doivent pouvoir s'exprimer
mais il ya des lignes éditoriales
soit on y va et puis on sait que c'est
un combat politique comme certains ont
décidé de le faire notamment sur ses
chaînes n'en soit on n'y va pas et puis
on essaie de créer
voilà des soies des médias alternatifs
soit en tout cas d'essayer de faire des
choses alternative parce que
effectivement quand on participe à ce
genre de dispositif est pas forcément on
peut pas après le critiquer on peut pas
aller sur touche pas à mon poste
faire un face à face avec jean messia et
pour moi d'un point de vue
journalistique est quelque chose de
complètement inutile que quelqu'un me
dit ce qu'est ce qui l'a retenu d'un
face à face entre ali ravet et jean
messia gens mais ça que déjà c'est qui
je remercie quelle est la légitimité de
jean messia a parlé de la ville de
trappes ou du problème politique qui se
fasse à trappes
mais voilà c'est un peu de spectacle
certes ça fait briller certes il ya
peut-être des trappistes qui se disent
ah tu perds notre mère nous défend bien
c'est peut-être aussi du coup politique
pour préparer la suite on est dans un
contexte quand même d'annulation des
électorale mais en tout cas moi quand
j'interviens après dans les collèges
pour parler d'éducation aux médias avec
les gamins si quelqu'un vient me dire
après oui mais toute façon les médias
c'est tous des menteurs et regardait
même le maire de trapil de 10 jeudi
après avoir longtemps il va pas tout à
fait dit ça mais bon voilà ça peut
devenir des arguments contre même les
politiques eux mêmes
on va refermer cette page concernant
trappe il nous reste une dizaine de
minutes d'émission va passer à nos
autres séquences mais juste peut-être
tout même à un mot et une remarque ce
sera peut-être l'occasion d'un autre
club de la presse pour parler d'une part
de ces politiques qui aujourd'hui
lancent par exemple en chaîne de télé
s'invite fond leur rôle en remplacent
les médias c'est aussi une vraie
question
et puis ces émissions dites de
divertissement qui aujourd'hui s'impose
comme des émissions politiques vous avez
parlé de gens mais ciac intervenait avec
cyril hanouna par exemple la qui a reçu
jean luc mélenchon aussi pour revenir
sur un plateau on n'est plus dans le du
divertissement et autres que dans un
message politique
est-ce que ça quelque part aussi ça
brouille pas les messages et ce serait
intéressant de dire venir pourquoi pas
avec les jeunes aussi con qu'on
rencontre régulièrement et vous parler
d'éducation tout à l'heure auprès des
jeunes
j'en parlais tout à l'heure sur la
semaine de la presse aussi qui
concernera tv 78 et passe à la partie
personnalité du mois à présent chaque
mois les journalistes deux de vos médias
locaux choisissent une personnalité
connue mais connue pour la mettre en
avant elles sont toutes qu un point
commun elles sont issues du département
nicolas pour radio sensations vous allez
revenir sur trappe
mais pour parler des habitants cette
fois ci oui c'est ça alors c'est du coup
c'est pas une personnalité mais encore
de personnalité si je puis me permettre
ce sont les habitants de trappes qu'on a
bien moins très peu entendu un peu comme
nous les médias locaux dans cette
polémique on les a entendus sur sur la
fin on va au bout de quelques jours on a
été tout de même les interroger sur ce
qu ils pensaient eux de la réalité de
leur ville avec des amis très nuancée et
plutôt gram positif
voilà on pense à eux parce que c'est eux
qui ont été le plus
impacté dans cette affaire qu'on dû être
affecté les parents et puis les lits
siens en général de trappes et du lycée
de la plaine la plaine 2 nov
on le sait le contexte n'est déjà pas
facile pour étudier aujourd'hui en
france et puis ailleurs en europe et la
communication qui était coupée avec
nicolas qui je le rappelle pour radio
sensations et en étant vision en duplex
avec nous on essaie de la rétablir
et on a bien compris toute façon déjà le
sens du message dans ses habitants qui
ont été victimes
bien malgré eux de cette image qui a été
donnée nicolas d'andria présent du côté
de tv 78 personnalités biennoises du
mois cet air sportif sportif et
direction en brésil rencontre avec
merrill loket 24 ans parra badistes de
l'équipe de france il est sportif de
haut niveau de parra badminton depuis
trois ans et demi maintenant il joue en
équipe de france et il a un palmarès
déjà bien rempli cinq fois champion de
france en simple 4 fois en double homme
double vice-champion d'europe en double
homme est actuellement ils s'entraînent
entre 3 et 4 heures par jour avec un
objectif de préparer les jeux
paralympiques de tokyo écoutez le c'est
quatre ans de préparation c'est du
stress est long et puis c'est le graal
quoi c'est le graal des compétitions et
puis on représente son pays à
l'international c'est moi y'a pas mieux
il c'est dur de se qualifier surtout
céder les meilleurs qui y vont et quand
on fait peut on faire partie de l'élite
des meilleurs c'est c'est tellement
c'est tellement bien à court terme
c'était de me qualifier aux jeux ça a
l'air d'être bien partit ensuite de
faire une médaille et après de me
préparer au mieux sans blessures surtout
pour les jeux de 2024 à paris et mairie
de loket a le soutien de la ville de
d'andrésy puisque le gymnase et a été
mise à disposition pour qu'il puisse
s'entraîner malgré la situation
sanitaire que l'on connaît et un soutien
financier a aussi été votée par la
municipalité
une bourse individuelle de 5000 euros
pour l'aider à se préparer à ces jeux
paralympiques qui c'est votre
personnalité du mois nicolas
kirillovitch lui est revenu avec nous
vim
voilà je les ai parlé voilà pour revenir
sur votre personnalité
allez-y défilé
revenue de manière très éphémère nicolas
gestion marchent marchent moins bien
alors nouradine c'est à vous que je
passe la parole à présent personnalité
du mois
oui tout à fait wilfrid alors pour un
petit peu taquiné mon confrère vous
voulez prendre les trappistes comme
personnalité de deux mois voilà c'est
vous croquer sa beauté c'est connaître
ça me passionne
voilà c'est ça c'est pour ça c'est moi
qui ait saboté son sa connexion voilà
pour vraiment une pensée très forte aux
habitants trappe qui en voit des vertes
et des pas mûres depuis bêtement une
trentaine d'années je ferme la
parenthèse la personnalité du coup que
j'ai choisie c'est tonton david qui est
voilà un des pionniers du reggae
français épi et qui est décédé récemment
tout récemment à l'âge de 53 ans et qui
avait fait un de ses tout premiers
concerts en 1992 le 20 novembre 1992 tu
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de cette
salle wilfrid c'était le bilbo à
elancourt mélenchon et voilà avec en
première partie frigia frigia avec voilà
qui l'a christophe pollet notamment qui
faisait partie de ce groupe local
il avait fait pour l'anecdote j'ai fait
la première partie la première partie de
tonton david pour taux d'avis de monte
sur scène il commence une chanson
bagarre générale
et puis le concert afin qu aller jusqu'à
l'os voyez c'est un peu son père a
expliqué mme guilbeault a été fermé pour
ça ensuite c'est une salle qui avait
effectivement une passe et un peu
sulfureux qui explique après sa
fermeture voilà pour ceux qui sont là
depuis plusieurs vingtaine d'années il
s'en souviendra peut-elle s'en
souviendront peut-être de cette salle on
va terminer là pour cette page
personnalité et on passe à notre
séquence bientôt à la une et en mars en
mars sur tv 78,30 deuxième semaine de la
presse et des médias à l'honneur rendez
vous annuel qui entend aider les élèves
de la maternelle au lycée à comprendre
les médias former leur jugement critique
développée à leur goût aussi pour
l'actualité se forger leur identité de
citoyen à cette occasion plusieurs
journalistes de la chaîne interviendront
dans des établissements du département
parler de la profession de l'information
ce sera aussi l'occasion d'échanger avec
ces jeunes de parler fait que news aussi
des rumeurs de voir comment ils
s'informent et puis après il y aura
aussi après ce qui s'est passé à la
trappe j'imagine on disait tout à
l'heure pas mal de questionnements aussi
de leur part et ce sera intéressant de
les entendre dès le 22 mars donc rendez
vous sur tv 60 18 à 18 heures pour
découvrir les reportages au quotidien 23
mars ce sera ensuite au tour de patrice
carmouze dans son émission paf de donner
la parole aux jeunes
et puis notez aussi le 26 mars de 7,8
week-end sera en grande partie composé
de reportages réalisés par des
collégiens et des lycéens ils auront
carte blanche et ils interviendront
aussi en plateau j'en profite si vous
êtes parent ou peut-être même élève
aussi pour vous donner l'adresse d'un
site c'est clemi point fr clemi c'est le
centre pour l'éducation aux médias cela
sert aux professeurs en général ça
permet aussi d'accompagner les parents
il ya plusieurs ressources des vidéos
avec des décryptages sur les stéréotypes
dans les médias décryptage d'image des
points de vue c'est un outil très
intéressant que je vous invite à
découvrir clemi point fr et puis semaine
de la presse donc à partir du 22 mars
sur tv est 78 sur marmite prochainement
nora dean wilfried clemi point fr
superbe site inconnu que je conseille
aux téléspectateurs téléspectatrices de
tv7 péter marmite et sensations oui la
semaine prochaine sur la vie des femmes
on va parler de d'anti-corruption avec
l'association anticor yvelines qui
viendra nous parler un petit peu des
dossiers chauds qui assure sur sur le
territoire et qu'on parlera également de
greenwashing
voilà comment certaines entreprises
essayent de se donner une image écolo
mais qui n'est pas toujours qui n'est
pas toujours vrai on a cédé deux sujets
principaux qu'on abordera la semaine
prochaine sur les 88 points 4 merci
beaucoup nouradine je remercie aussi
nicolas kirillovitch qui n'a pas réussi
récit et qui n'ont rejoint nicolas vous
nous rejoignez j'allais juste conclure
l'émission vous allez avoir si vous ne
nous entendez bien vous êtes la seule
rédaction cette fois ci pour ceux qui
ont l'image en rédaction de radio
sensations
peut-être un peu juste sur le
le passage en des abbés plus qu'est-ce
que les plus que date plus ce n'est pas
une nouvelle danse c'est la radio de
demain entre autre équipe bis à la radio
numérique terrestre
et si la radio qui va se propager
progressivement dans toute la france à
partir de cet été dans 25 radio
nationale seront seront disponibles
grâce à la dea avaient plus mais en fait
radio sensations et déjà sur andy avait
plus et donc vous pouvez écouter la de
sensations de grâce à cette nouvelle
radio partout en ile de france il ya
plus il n'ya pas besoin d'aller sur
internet en fait c'est d'avoir ainsi
juste un récepteur particulier qu'il
faut se procurer a besoin d'abonnement
c'est gratuit la nouvelle radio et grâce
à ce récepteur vous capterez la radio tu
es ab plus et vous aurez le choix avec
beaucoup plus de radio à présent que
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui que votre
radio en voiture ou autre vous avez je
sais pas 25 ou 30 radios disponibles et
radio nationale et quelques radios
locales
demain avec la dfb plus quand elle sera
accessible partout vous aurez accès à
100 150 radios c'est en résumé si c'est
la tnt
mais pour la radio et qui arrive
progressivement et radio sensations et
en des abbés plus avant les radios
nationales
félicitations à vous pour les coupures
internet
malgré le passage en diable et plus sûr
encore désirer s'adresser aux mêmes là
effectivement
merci beaucoup nicolas donc pour radio
sensations 98,4 sur le département des
yvelines merci nicolas landry aussi pour
tv 78 on vous retrouve prochainement
pour un prochain numéro à de sky écho au
magazine économique consacrée à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on termine cette émission peut-être en
musique un petit extrait qu'on n'a pas
diffusé de tonton david et puis je vous
donne rendez vous au mois prochain merci
à vous tous et merci de nous avoir
suivis merci
sommaire le soit mais céda pas plus
qu'il ne veut plus souffrir
un peuple qui a beaucoup souffert nous
sommes monsieur d'un peuple qui ne veut
plus souffrir mais resterait tout témoin
attentivement au micro original je ne
veux pas perdre mon temps le dépôt de
votre coeur vers l'utopie sion avant la
fin c'est bien plus fort que d'avoir de
l'argent regarde là c'est de la chance
et désespérant doucement calebasse halak
est le monde est un puissant et les
choses ont toujours en évoluant entre
hotton paix entre les noirs et des
blancs
[Musique]